[Music]
you know
[Music]
you can make some or some of the
people's do so must do to me Academy I
like
because I want to do this thing it was
just a payphone
finding a deal picking up the phone just
talking be going through wants the one
major than you making a grandmother
guess what every single person doing but
because the beat or no the rejection
feels painful but they just told me that
they don't you can put that
rejected by thanks obviously get some
stage and usually you don't want a
frickin
I apologize dirty thing and doesn't know
how it is
ready to break is very very legal it's
very very technical so what we do think
for a minute is when you're going to do
biggest thing is you're positioning a
new standard when you the place you're
coming from when you think from it about
what value because before you can sell
and believe me you've got a cell sample
disparity the sounds is not dirty that
was just business
everything these sales your jobs can
only pay because the company makes sales
sales as equals income if you don't like
sales you can make income